foreign
cheetah joins us in Orlando cheetah
welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you guys thank you for taking my
call sure
so basically I have kind of like a
two-part question so I found y'all
because I was so stressed out my
refrigerator refrigerator broke down I
didn't know how I was going to afford it
all my credit cards are expected out and
so I started looking at loans and then I
on YouTube and I was and then I came
across Dave Ramsey so I've been looking
at y'all I've been watching your videos
I've been looking at the baby steps and
so right now my baby step one I saved up
a thousand but I don't know should I
save up more just in case my
refrigerator breaks down is the
refrigerator running
yeah right now we're just running again
I almost want to hit the punchline Ken I
won't do it why you should go catch it
oh there it is
well cheetah uh first of all thank you
for being one of our new listeners when
was the last time you just took a deep
breath
has it been a while has life been
stressful
it has
well we teach the baby steps in order it
hasn't changed in 30 years and that's
for a good reason they work every time
you work it and regardless of what
inflation is doing and what what life is
happening you need these quick wins so I
love that you already have that thousand
dollars and you're worried because
you've had something happen in the past
that's triggering you going what if it's
not enough what if it's not enough
that's where this is coming from
yeah how much debt do you have
um I have 15 in credit cards and 7 000
in my car fifteen thousand on the credit
cards
yes and seven thousand on the car what's
your interest rate on those credit cards
I
got 26 hello
all right now I asked you on purpose I
knew it was going to be a crazy number
like that and even you had a hard time
getting that out of your mouth because
it's so painful
the reason I asked you that question is
because that's the answer to your first
question the reason you only put a
thousand dollars in that emergency fund
is just to cover something like a fridge
going out and you could be able to cover
a repair to that well what we've got to
do is we've got to put every extra
dollar
not into the emergency fund but to
paying off the fifteen thousand dollars
in credit cards my goodness 26 on that
you ought to just do the math on that on
what you're paying just an interest
alone and that'll get to the point where
you're throwing up in your mouth now I'd
say rather graphic reference but that's
what this needs to be it is I know I
found y'all yeah so hey here's the good
news you can knock this out okay but
that's why you don't put a thousand in
five dollars or a thousand and two
hundred dollars it's a thousand dollars
now move everything else into the baby
steps that George is you know gonna walk
you through so you how many credit cards
do you have
I have
Bill boy she had to pause to remember
eight eight credit cards what's the
smallest balance
working on the baby step so the smallest
is 35 and I got that paid off today then
the next one is 106. and I'm gonna have
the two more paid off by the end of
October nice do you feel the excitement
that you just had in your voice you see
what happened there yeah that was the
happiest you've been on this whole call
physiological change in the way you
begin to talk about paying off debt so
what's your income
it is 2 400 a month but I'm starting to
pick up overtime boom over time and
listen part-time jobs right now are at a
all-time premium in this economy
yeah I have a part-time job as well what
are you making in that part-time job per
hour
um fifteen dollars not enough I keep
doing that but I'd look for something
that's paying you 20 to 22 an hour
you got it I mean we're like we're going
after every extra nickel that we can get
in the door
yeah on top of that have you cut all of
your expenses I've been picking up at
least at least 20 hours of overtime at
my current job that pays me already 40
hours of work awesome oh I like that
okay and you're not investing right now
no uh well they both automatically
already take 401K out it's automatic
like you can't stop that
I have no idea I haven't looked into
that yet let's look into that and see if
they can pause that temporarily so that
you can take whatever amount that is and
be throwing that at the debt because at
26 this thing is going to be a cycle
that will never end if we don't stomp
this thing fast
yeah have you cut up those eight cards
like cut them up into itsy bitsy pieces
well some of them I loved uh and then
the other ones I was looking at
yesterday with the scissors well that's
more reason to shut that thing down what
if someone's using it right now
mm-hmm okay no no no no no no no no no
no no no not like as soon as this call
is over I would report it all of those
companies saying hey I lost my car I
lost my credit now so I want to close
this account as soon as I'm paying off
yeah
I have a little heartburn myself right
now on the lost credit cards I need to I
need some may locks you meet some tons
again Tom's there she remembered the
Tums oh you remember you were watching
the show and I ate Tums live on the air
yeah the Citrus tons wow I love it she's
a great listener and I've been watching
every day you are awesome Dave Ramsey
every moment the fabulous ones are [ __ ]
brewing sponsorship we need a tum
sponsor somebody get on the phone with
Tums please I'm a perfect spokesperson
for that well
is there anything we can do to help have
you been through Financial Peace
University
no I haven't we're gonna take care of
you about to today tell her what she's
won George she's won one year Financial
Peace University can nine lessons that
will change the way you handle your
money cheetah so hang on the line
Austin's gonna pick up we're also gonna
throw in every dollar the premium
version to connect to your bank account
and help you track every single one of
those overtime dollars coming in you are
gonna crush this thing and I cannot wait
to hear your debt-free scream yes this
is what I'm here for Ken yeah a new
listener who's going
I had eight cards and I thought I was
winning and I started them going I'll
never pay a diamond interest I'm gonna
get rewards and cash back and then it
becomes the emergency fund it was just
on Fox and Friends this morning and they
were talking about the crazy amounts of
credit card debt soaring like wildfire
yeah here we are and all those people
opened it thinking well I'm gonna pay it
off every month sure and it's wise
because you get the cash back and the
rewards and here we are
887 billion dollars in credit card debt
as a nation that's where we are right
now yes
20. listen
I did not know well I knew the rate was
going to be high the interest rate on a
credit card when she told me 26 percent
I almost spit into the mic it was I
really held it back it was
26 percent
these companies are predatory they're
not your friend they're not sending you
on vacation for free they are winning
the game George and it's on the backs of
struggling Americans yeah like cheetah
who are paying 26 interest so that you
can brag about your free vacation you
got on credit card points this is sad
George I think we need to organize a
protest in front of all these corporate
credit card I'm here for buildings
American distress we're coming for you
oh yeah I like that I was one of them
Ken I used to think that way and then I
cut up the Discover Card cut up my AmEx
Sky miles and now I just pay for my
vacations myself yeah and you say it
feels great you save me money with your
hat Southwest hack good stuff 160 bucks
you save feels good to take control and
you can to America we're here for